congratulations
every year now we expect emmy
nominations except this year we want to
win we really want to win guys please
this is our year it's our best season
voters are watching i would imagine come
on voters
why don't we we have heavy competition i
know rupaul untucked and i know uh
a couple other netflix shows
yeah a great show too so unfortunately i
don't want it to win though
yeah i love it but not that much cheer
is on there there's a couple of good
shows that we like yeah what was your
reaction when you guys heard the news we
were actually on the tarmac heading back
from europe yesterday when we found out
yeah it was a nice piece of information
to get the producer did a group text for
all of us and we were all so excited oh
yeah i wish i had my phone on me it was
a great way to end a vacation i'd show
you
yeah are you guys team ryan gosling or
team chris evans what that woman that's
so beautiful on that yeah
and i'm on her team oh goodness come on
day arm is that her what's her name anna
yeah
but i would say you're single do you
know him
listen you'll find that out you're et
you're supposed to know everybody but
listen right
he's a good-looking dude i i mean i will
call it where it is he's a good-looking
dude
captain america he's a good looking dude
too do we like the stash or no
i should can i say i didn't notice it
yeah i don't look at men to say what you
do i don't notice everything yeah
we're the guys that like our girlfriends
get our hair done and we're like uh
guys don't notice other guys at all yeah
so
yeah you're the wrong people to ask okay
fine fine well you guys don't have a
stash really you guys keep it pretty
clean yeah we got some greys coming in
so you know we're not trying to go too
long but yeah you guys are always fresh
from europe fresh yacht trip sold
mansion this is such a good timing my
tan hasn't gone away yet oh my god okay
so
there's going to be new seasons of
selling sunset
who's going to be the villain
[Music]
no i'm kidding
who knows there may be like uh new
people i think there's a couple i think
there might be a couple this year really
yeah
and one of them you might not
no i don't know
we have a lot going on this year in
terms of like the the level of real
estate we are we're in like 20 30 40
million dollar deals right now that
we're that we're filming um maybe
six figure millions i mean we this this
season six and seven are gonna be
the i think the real estate's going to
be elevated every year that's difficult
but i think we are this time i think
we're going to keep going oh i love that
well i believe in you guys and i always
love watching you guys so
congratulations
and selling oc airs in like in a few
weeks so i love selling ocs it's gonna
be it's gonna be awesome
it's him thank you guys always a
pleasure
you